[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money and your career and whatever else
you want to talk about i'm george
campbell your host joined by my
colleague and best-selling author ken
coleman host of the ken coleman show
just came hot off the ken coleman show
didn't you right george i'm two hours in
i'm already warmed up i'm stretched you
can do three more oh sure three more
it's no problem at all it beats working
for a limit that's true you know what i
mean
some schlep is digging a ditch right now
and he's going i need more i need to
listen to the ken coleman show i need to
call uh the ramsay show today i i need
to get out of this ditch and uh i'm
thinking to myself yeah you're right
because it could be worse absolutely you
know what i mean answering questions
coaching people for five hours
i mean i'm not gonna gripe a lot nobody
wants to hear me gripe about that no
there's results in that that's one thing
you talk about is being on mission to
helping people win and by the way george
today you and i are together so we're
talking about money and meaning we're
talking about income and impact i love
the alliteration you'll like that i like
that you also said colleague because
last friday we were together on the
ramsay show and i said colleague and
you're a millennial and you're like uh
you hadn't heard the word very much it's
a ten dollar word for a guy like me i'll
tell you that much
colleague i say work buddy
is that what you said i don't know i
don't know what i'd say we call them
team members around here because uh we
don't really like the word employee
feels a little stiff yeah just i don't
care what you say just don't call me
work buddy okay ever i'll stay away from
that okay well it's a free call today
triple eight eight two five five two two
five give us a call kelly will put you
through tell her george sent you i don't
know if that's good enough i like that
maybe today it is i like that yeah can
we host it friday and here we are again
and i call that a devil blessing it is a
double blessing did you have a good
weekend i did how about yourself oh
fantastic you watched the big game the
big games george we what football is a
sport football watching is a sport in
the coleman house uh
with the amount of do you know what the
nfl red zone is george i i heard about
it you've heard about it
it sounds real hot red zone well it's a
way of life in the coleman household and
uh we only get up to go to the restroom
or get more food and beverage and we're
watching football for several hours it's
it's a wonderful wonderful thing it's an
american tradition and so is the ramsay
show it is 30 years in we're doing this
and i'm excited to take your calls today
with my colleague ken we're going to
kick it off in cleveland ohio with mike
mike welcome to the ramsay show
thank you thanks for having me
absolutely how can we help
all right so i have had a long history
of debt um
like credit cards and stuff like that i
have all that paid off um i'm a one
income household now a single dad i have
my kids 55 of the time
um i have a truck payment and i have a
uh a mortgage
my um
my question is should i
pay my truck off
and keep it and then work on my house or
should i sell it it's a fairly expensive
truck um
so i guess that's my question what is
this truck worth right now if you sold
it today in this hot market what do you
think you can get for it
it's a uh
i think around 34 000 and i owe uh 29
and a half
okay so you would profit about five
grand off of this thing and you'd get
out from under the truck payment and
you'd have five grand to put towards a a
car
correct and you can buy cars for five
grand
absolutely my other question with that
is
now aside from my uh yearly income i do
have options within my job i'm a police
officer i can
cash out vacation holiday and a little
bit of sick time as long as we don't
call off six of the year
i've totaled up everything and it comes
to about 22 000
over the year wow so next year
uh from
basically from this december we cash out
every holiday so it's kind of like a
nice christmas check
but from this december until next
december i i could come up with
um
just over twenty thousand dollars um and
i was going to try my best to pay my
truck off uh and not have a car payment
starting january 1st 2023 hey mike let
me ask you a question
are you pulling uh like uh direct i
don't know if they do this in cleveland
ohio in in nashville tennessee
if you go driving around on a sunday
morning around 11 o'clock in between 9
11 you got police officers out there
directing traffic coming in and out of
churches getting a lot of overtime high
school football games are you maxing out
your overtime possibilities as a police
officer
so i do uh when it's uh
kind of first come first serve when you
sign up for it i do work as much as
possible i do have another part-time job
i work at a hospital
um as uh
as with as a police officer with my
department but i work alongside the
security there so that's an extra side
job so um are you figuring that out
are you figuring that into
this other equation you just gave us
no i'm not figuring any overtime and
also that is not counting
um
the
monthly payments throughout the year
that is just extra money that i can cash
out
uh
some now and then obviously some next
december when it comes to that time
again
yeah so what ken is getting at is could
you keep the truck and pay this thing
off pretty quickly and it sounds like
you could there's nothing wrong with
keeping this but based on the fact that
you are willing to get rid of it so
quickly which is rare for a truck owner
it tells me you're not in love with this
truck and you'd rather clean up this
this debt and just have the mortgage to
grapple with is that
right uh kind of uh i actually do love
the truck and there we go um i've been
i've had it for about a year and a half
now uh the only owner i take very good
care of it so my my thought process is
if i can do this if i can pay this off
by december 31st of next year 2022
can i just keep this truck
absolutely and move forward to my
mortgage yeah i think you can do it
faster than that what's your household
income
without the overtime
um is this before or after taxes uh
let's say before
all right before taxes is 96 000
however i have a i have um child support
that i pay a thousand dollars a month
for so at the beginning so it's 12 000
less
for that okay
so it feels like if you took some
overtime could you get rid of this thing
in under a year
i'm hoping i know
so my goal is a year but you know
uh with all the overtime and uh extra
jobs i think once i get that thing down
to you know near closer to zero then i'm
just going to work really hard
once you see the light at the end of the
tunnel you're gonna go full throttle on
this thing gazelle intense
absolutely yeah absolutely
i love it um i do have my uh i do have
about five grand in the bank right now
and that is after i've paid off all my
uh debts and everything i do have my uh
emergency fund of a thousand dollars
um
my other question though is i should i
um should i skip uh baby step four um
which is saving uh for the retirement i
believe right yeah
should you skip it i do have a retire
not
not skip the baby step maybe add to it
um because i already have my retirement
setup and i do put a little bit more
than i uh have to
into it i want you to continue on i i
don't want you changing up the plan here
keep doing the 15 you can keep the truck
but i want this thing gone in under a
year with this income and with this
overtime and if you've got cash throw it
at that car i want you to get rid of
this thing asap so you can live your
life man but you're doing great
appreciate your service as a police
officer
more the ramsey show coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
i'm george campbell host of the fine
print and entre leadership podcast
joined today by ken coleman host of the
ken coleman show and we are taking your
calls triple eight eight two five
five two two five you know right now
you're probably focused on all the false
stuff you've gotta buy the halloween
candy the jackets and sweaters it's
pumpkin spice latte season but here's
what you should start thinking about
right now christmas christmas seems to
sneak up on people every year and when
you let that happen it's so easy to go
crazy on overspending or worse put
christmas on a credit card don't do this
when you plan ahead with a budget you'll
keep christmas from getting out of
control and the best way to do that is
with our budgeting tool every dollar
you can start your christmas budget
right now by deciding how much you want
to save each month and plug that into
your every dollar budget so you can pay
for christmas in cash then when you
start shopping your every dollar makes
it easy for you to keep up with how much
you're spending on gifts and by the way
it's totally free to get started or you
can upgrade to a ramsey plus membership
and get premium features like syncing
with your bank that allows you to just
drag and drop your transactions into
your budget and all kinds of custom
reports to show you where your money is
going guys christmas is coming it's not
a surprise and this year you can
actually enjoy the holiday how it should
be stress free and debt free start
budgeting with every dollar by texting
the word budget to
33789 that's budget to 33789
maria is with us in austin texas maria
welcome to the ramsay show
marie are you with us
yes hi hey can you hear me yes how can
we help today
hi
okay so um
me and my husband were in our 30s we
went through and
we got all of our debts paid
and we own our own house
um we're we're so blessed with that
you just um right on by that you're in
your 30s and you've got a paid for house
and no debt way to go yeah thank you
okay so um here's the deal i'm having an
issue with oh
i think that we're kind of you know like
thrifty people we're not like and beyond
our means we're not
um just we like to um
anyway so here's the deal we're gonna
sell our house okay it's up for sale um
but we're diving into a new mortgage to
live closer to town we have three kids i
don't like involved with stuff and
we travel like 20
miles i mean yeah 20 miles to get to
town every day and it's like a lot of
back and forth and we're just like we
just want to be a little closer
so
anyway i was just i'm having these like
issues i'm thinking are we
making
you're wondering is it a wise financial
move to get back into a mortgage you're
in baby step seven you're saying hey
this will put us back into baby step six
how much is the house how much is the
house you're looking at buying
well um it's a hundred and
sorry you're breaking up on us maria try
speaking directly into the phone
sorry uh it's 196.
196 the new house
uh no no i'm sorry the um 179.
okay what's the house you're selling now
what's that one worth
maria did we lose you
oh boy oh no we were just we were so
we're getting to the good part
it doesn't sound like this is a huge
cost we'll see if we can get back did i
understand her right that's 179 000
yeah let's see if we can get her back
because i mean i i'm on the edge of my
seat myself i know uh it can't look like
it was going to come down to a simple
math equation but if they did get to get
back into a mortgage it sounded like it
wouldn't be much
depending on what their current house
did i hear correctly that's 179 is the
house they want to buy that's what i
heard
and they've got a paid for house which i
imagine is going to be in the ballpark i
would hope i don't know they're moving
20 minutes into town i don't know i mean
how much you could get her back here's
what i would tell maria yeah if you need
to take on a 10 20 dollar mortgage there
we go all right maria are you back with
us
oh my gosh maria's back come on maria
pull through
all right it was a good effort okay oh
there we go i can hear you i can hear
you okay sorry let's get to the brass
tax here what's your current house
selling for
uh we put it on the market for uh 4.97
4.97
yeah and it's paid for
yes and what's this new house worth that
you want
um well
it's it's a hundred and seventy nine
thousand is what we're getting for our
our loan
oh for the loan okay see
okay we were very confused we thought
that's what the house
was going to be maria what just so we
are all on the same page
how much is the total price i don't want
to know your loan amount what is the
price of the home that you want to buy
in town
it is
i'm thinking after we get everything
that with like what we want to improve
on it's going to be in the like 225
range
i'm further baffled down really so if
you sell this house you're going to have
a half million dollars in cash basically
right
yeah
so you don't need a mortgage so where is
all that money going
well
the house right now um
it's it's uh being built it's a mobile
home
um
okay i just thought it was a smart thing
because it's
you know we've got more questions than
answers here okay maria okay all right
maria i'm gonna take one more shot at
this okay maria
you are asking us
should you take a mortgage out on a home
in town you're 20 minutes outside of
town
and your current home is worth basically
just under a half a million dollars the
one that you've listed you've listed at
just under half a million true or false
true okay if you sell it for that you
already own it free and clear you're
gonna have that number
minus your commission to your real
estate agent are you still tracking with
me
yes i am and i'm on board with that i'm
just like in this market are we gonna
sell for i mean
are we diving into like too fast no no
you're not but you're not diving into
anything this sounds like a really nice
gentle stroll because you're going to
buy a house for less than half of what
your current house is worth in town and
you're going to pay cash for it
no mortgage
if our house sells here right so you
have fear the house isn't going to sell
yeah well then you don't wash it well
then you don't move until you it's a
contingent so with your real estate you
go look if we sell this house then we're
going to put an offer on this so you got
a really good real estate agent a ramsey
trusted real estate agent you got one of
those
a good
a good one picked out so okay
i don't know what you're afraid even if
it sells for 50 grand less you're still
going to be able to pay cash for this
next house plus repairs and anything you
want to do today you don't need a
mortgage
okay now did you say this is a mobile
home that you're going into or out of
uh both
yeah so this current you're in a mobile
home worth half a million dollars
well uh we have acreage oh there's some
land attached to it yeah okay
yeah
well are you going into another mobile
home
yes
and what's the reason behind
that um just
because uh
i don't know i guess we just wanted
something new and something kind of fast
well my worry is that with a mobile home
it's going to be a depreciating asset
it's not going to grow in value like a
single family traditional home would be
so
are there traditional homes in in that
area you want to move to that are in the
similar price point
oh um
no i i guess really just
on something new and all the house like
building a house would just be you know
expensive you don't need to build one
from scratch i mean there's plenty of
homes people are selling that are single
family homes maria george is being
really really nice i gotta tell you
something it's a bad idea for you to
cash out of this current situation and
go get another mobile home it doesn't
make sense it's gonna depreciate in
value go get something a little bit
smaller something that'll take care of
the family maybe you can fix it up a
little bit pay cash for it
and uh keep living your life but to go
into a mobile home is a horrible idea
let me just say that don't do that you
don't need to
if this is about a better life well then
let's not make a bad decision on the
place we're going to live in it's a
depreciating asset don't do it i don't
like this
that was a roller coaster ken but we got
off the ride safely
good thing we're wearing our seat belts
i got some whiplash on that i'm gonna
have to get my head together for the
next segment
all right this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast joined today
by ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author host of the ken
coleman show
and
from paycheck to purpose ken it's coming
real soon the new book hot on the heels
hot on the heels what's going on with
this book well it's uh it's the tool
that i wanted to have two years ago
three years ago
but as with anything george uh you gotta
you gotta put the time in to make sure
it's the right tool
and we're approaching now five thousand
phone calls in the last four years wow
on the ken coleman show and so this book
from paycheck to purpose is the full
clear path the subtitle is the clear
path to doing work you love but what is
the book it's the seven stages um on how
to figure out what it is that you're
supposed to do with your life work where
you really love it you're making the
income and the impact
and then how do you figure out what it
is then how do you actually get there
and then be great at it that's the short
version it's the full journey super
practical the seven stages and it's for
anybody who just wants more out of their
work
whether it's dream job or not i i want
to do better i want to make more money
ken how can i make more money
to get out of debt faster well the book
will help you some of you go i'm making
the money i just want more meaning the
book will help you so it is uh it's the
entire path
and uh it's going to really equip and
encourage it's not a motivational book
it's it's it'll inspire you make you
laugh and cry but it is a very practical
book that'll allow you
to stop being miserable on monday
mornings america needs that with this
great result needs it yeah yeah well
it's less than a month away from launch
we're excited about it you can pre-order
it right now
ramsay solutions.com is the place to go
you get a lot of pre-order goodies
audiobook e-book uh you name it so make
sure to tune in to that and jump onto
randysolutions.com and grab your copy
we're gonna go to the phones we've got
summer in scottsdale arizona summer
welcome to the ramsey show hi can you go
hear me okay yes how you doing how can
we help hi um hi this is exciting i've
never been on the ramsay show so
we're just as excited
uh i just had a quick question so um i
have two jobs right now i have a day job
i'm a loan officer associate for a bank
and then at night um i work in bars in
old town scottsdale
and because
i can
save i have the ability to say that i do
save um
between 40 and 60 of my net income um
every month
so but i do have some student loan debt
and also i owe a little bit of money on
my car
so i was wondering if my student i plan
on paying off my card this month um and
that will just be gone
um but i have about thirty two thousand
dollars in student loan debt
but my interest rate on my student loan
debt is very very very low about less
than two percent so i was just wondering
if you think it would be stupid of me to
put about 25 of my income towards my
student loan and then 25 just into like
a cash savings account investing or
whatever
um what i'm hearing is you're wanting to
do a few things at once you're wanting
to pay off the debt but you also wanted
to stack up some savings and what i
recommend is focusing on one thing at a
time and that's what we teach in the
baby steps and so we teach to start with
that thousand dollar savings which it
sounds like you have right now you've
got a thousand dollars in cash right
yeah and once you have that what you
want to do is list out your debts from
smallest to largest which which it
sounds like the car loan is the smallest
debt you have right now
and that'll be gone this month and
that'll be gone this month which means
we're really focusing on the student
loan and so what i want you to do there
is stop saving right now stop uh
stocking away that cash do you have more
cash other than a thousand dollars
oh yeah i have about um fourteen
thousand dollars in cash right now after
my car's paid off there we go and that's
aside from the thousand dollar emergency
fund or is that all lumped in there
um no about 13 and so 14 total so uh
including the emergency so if i'm you
what i'm doing is taking 13 000 and
slapping it on the student loan getting
rid of that and putting the rest on the
car and that's going to take down that
car loan to what 20 grand maybe
under 24. the car will be gone after the
cars paid off i have 13 000 in cash
fantastic so that means you're down to
uh what 19
19 000 on the car
and with all this extra income
no she said she keeps saying the car is
gone so after the car now she now she
can slash 32 000 on the student loan
yeah and you have 13 you can throw on
that that's huge which would bring that
down to 19 uh total on the student loan
and with this extra income that you have
coming in which is fantastic that you're
you can save all that instead of putting
it in savings i want you to attack that
debt uh so that you can be debt free my
guess is within a few months at this
rate is that possible yeah
um probably about yeah i make about 6
000 a month usually so if i put 3 000
towards debt
um that was hard yeah about six months
yeah if you've got 19 left that's about
six months that's fantastic summer what
a game changer that is in your life i
want you to just soak on that for a
moment how would that feel
pretty good
yeah what's great ken is that she's
she's got the discipline down the work
ethic is there yeah um you're just
trying to do multiple things at once and
what i want is for you to feel the
progress of seeing this debt gone so
that you free up the payment from the
car loan the payment that you were
making towards that student loan and we
don't really we don't care about
interest rate what we care about is
getting the biggest
wealth building tool back in your life
which is your income momentum summer do
you see what george is telling you this
is gets you the most momentum and it
just powers you through this
so yeah thank you guys so much yeah you
bet you're impressive call us back when
you're dead free i'd love to hear the
dead free scream on this one yeah she's
busting it too sacrificing getting after
it hear that she's doing my day job and
then i'm working the bars down in old
town scottsdale and she's not scared to
work and that that is the number one
indicator that you're going to be able
to get out of this debt no question
about that i love it all right we're
moving to antoinette in orlando florida
antoinette well welcome to the ramsay
show hi how are you guys doing great how
can we help
um so i a month before i started the
final financial peace university i
consolidated a lot of my debt into my
mortgage
which i would probably not do now having
started this class
um so i have a total about 269 000 um
all in my mortgage but i have two rental
properties and by consolidating um both
of them are paid off essentially
speaking
so my question for you is should i sell
one of the rental properties that has
always been rented brings in about 1600
a month and use that to completely
become debt free
or should i just continue to attack the
debt
and keep those to
the investment property so what debt do
you have right now currently outside of
your primary residence
okay so what i rolled into my mortgage
um was a boat loan
a
home equity line which i had used to buy
one round of properties and then one of
the rental property mortgages
and you're saying you could get
completely debt free and get out of all
this if you sold one of the rental
properties
correct do it
how would that feel does that do you
feel like a weight would be lifted
so i get a lot of pushback from family
we have a lot of rental um
gurus in our panel
people
so they go
antoinette don't do that that's not a
wise financial move
the rental is bringing an income what
are you doing yeah but you're paying but
you're paying off you're paying off a
boat you're paying off all those other
things you put into it
do you want to do it do you want to do
what your family's telling you do or do
you want to be debt-free and then be
even richer and more wealthy than they
are
i want to be that free for sure yeah
well you can do it with one one i just i
needed an extra blessing
do it
i've said that's the third time i've
said it don't make him say it again
don't make me spell it again all right
great
oh that's fantastic no i i think here's
the thing once you have that income back
in your life and your debt free you're
gonna be able to save up and pay cash
for your next investment property but it
sounds like you've just been you've been
on a joy spree a spending spree going i
want the boat let's do the heloc let's
buy some investment property and based
on the people around you it looks like
wow we're crushing it financially yeah
but you're feeling the weight of the
payments aren't you yeah
oh yeah i hate i hate that i hate it
with a passion how much do you like that
boat by the way uh if i could convince
my husband to sell it i would have no
problem selling it there it is i'd start
working that angle too
that goes toward the next rental
property
exactly exactly the boat is probably not
bringing you guys income like a rental
is
no it's bringing stress relief but i
think once we're debt-free that'll also
bring a lot of stress relief as well
yeah i'd sell the house pay off all the
debt then go for a boat ride there we go
i like it i like this plan a lot hey
antoinette we're rooting for you way to
go you're cleaning this mess up and
you're gonna have a whole pile of money
coming into your life when you get rid
of this debt you're doing the right
thing don't listen to family members
listen to george listen to me i'm family
now
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by ken
coleman this is the ramsey show it's a
free call triple eight eight two five
five two two five you've got a question
about money
life your career your purpose your
calling
ken and i are here for you even if you
just need some confirmation ken a lot of
the times people just go hey i think i
know the answer yeah but i took three
calls today on the ken coleman show
people literally have
new opportunities they're going do i
stay where i am do i take this new
opportunity so we'll talk about those
fork in the road questions hey listen if
you're just going you know what i know
there's more uh i feel like i'm a part
of the 55 percent of americans who are
going i'm actively looking for something
else what should i be looking for
we'll walk you through it um today's the
day um you know because you know you're
super nice i'm pretty nice there's
nothing to be afraid this is the day to
call in yeah i'm not going to beat you
up and if you need some confirmation
you're going hey my my broke
brother-in-law said this i read a
headline i was in a reddit thread uh
call us up and we can walk you through
that situation with a with a clean just
a clean slate good head on our shoulders
no bias
i want to make more money
how do i make some more money in the
short term so i can apply it to the baby
steps let's go we'll help you with the
shovel the shovel is important triple
eight eight two five five two two five
angela is in austin texas angela welcome
to the ramsay show
hi how are you doing great how can we
help
um well this is
here it is uh where my husband and i
we've been debt free for a number of
years
and
we have a lot of money in the bank right
now and we need to move it because it's
it's it's approaching to a very big
number how big is this number
uh it's 500
plus five hundred thousand dollars just
sitting in your bank account
yes and uh
he's uh he works for the government he's
a civilian
and uh so we have income i'm retired
military we have income coming there we
wanted to buy a business
this last two years the cobit hit so
we're reluctant to even invest in
anything even even real estate because
right now we're trying to
basically just be mobile wherever that
is
and you don't want to be tied down we
have it
correct correct so you know we're now
we're empty nesters we want to we don't
know what we want to do when we grow up
is basically what it is but we have this
money and it's not really working for us
and i'm just with the information coming
down with this administration
i'm i'm nervous
so where did this money how did you
accumulate this money and how fast
um well we
soon see the civilian we went we went
overseas i've been retired for about
about 10 years so we try to live on my
pension from the military as much as we
can so we went overseas and he makes
good money we just sucked that away for
five years in addition to when we went
overseas we sold our house we had a
little income from there and we just
really live below our means we have one
car
we're renting
um i mean my cars are 2014. you say
you're renting because you're not there
for a while
yes we're looking you know do we move to
tennessee do we go with family in
georgia do we just buy here i don't know
you know so since those are the unknowns
for us we want our money to work for us
and we
just feel we need to either split it up
and put it in different piles do you
have it in one account right now
yes okay well number one i i you should
split that and here's the reason your
money is fdic insured up to 250 000
which means if your bank just went out
of business today uh you're backed for
250 which means you lose half your money
so i want you to at least split that up
and you can look into uh
the the rules around can i just put it
in two different accounts or does it
need to be with a different bank uh
check with your bank as to how that
would work but i want to make sure your
money's at least protected right now and
then as far as growing it i see you're
you're saying hey we i know we can do
better with this money i don't want you
throwing it into um into the market
investing it if you're gonna need it
anytime soon and it sounds like you just
don't know there's a lot of unknowns
right now
yeah correct
now what you could do is invest part of
it you could you know work with a smart
investor pro and say hey we're gonna put
a hundred thousand dollars into some
mutual funds in a brokerage account
outside of retirement and just let it
grow until we know what we want to do
with that
but as far as the money goes what i
would do is put it in a high-yield
savings account right now you could get
uh about a half a percent to a percent
depending on where you go uh and that
would at least help grow your money in a
safe way where it's still very
accessible okay okay angela how soon
before you guys are going to be locking
in on a decision some of the decisions
that you just shared with us
about where we're living primarily yes i
i think probably uh within four months
if some things don't work out with a new
location then we'll probably just build
routes here buy a home
uh
and then just write it out so he retires
and so that's kind of where we are
yeah
well and so let's just say that the
decision was made today okay yeah that
we were either going tennessee georgia
or staying in texas
what would you do with that money today
if that decision was already made
well um then i i would say we we would
we would take that money probably
don't laugh or just probably move into a
mobile home
on some land and probably fish and live
on my retirement so it just kind of
evens out to be honest with you
okay so you see where i'm going with
this that means
you've already got a plan for it and
what it's going to be is it's going to
be cash you're going to cash you're
going to pay cash for wherever you're
going to live and finish out
yes well then i'd be you know i mean
georgia's right i protect your money uh
in the short term but you guys need to
make a decision and once you make a
decision that money's going to be spent
on paying cash
so you don't owe a dime for anything and
you may have some left over after you
buy a house or whatever you're going to
do correct yes yes yes yeah i just think
you're overthinking it let's make a
decision stop spending all this time
worrying about how much money you got in
the bank which you shouldn't be worried
about anything good on you guys good job
let's make a decision on where we want
to to drop anchor and let's drop anchor
and then spend that money on on that the
only thing i would challenge you on is
the is the mobile home it's just you
know why not buy a nice little home or
build a nice little home uh something
that i say
well say a little louder seems like hubs
needs to hear that louder yeah yeah is
he not wanting to be locked locked into
something
i think that's where it is because you
know we're getting older and you know
what i what i thought retirement was
going to be it's not and it's okay i
mean it's a good life i mean we're
moving around we're traveling um what
did you want retirement to
be kind of still that but i i don't i've
been we've been mobile so long with the
military that uh
i feel like you want to plant roots
i do i really do i want i wanted to be
able to say this is home and come back
to it you know i'm originally from
california and uh and i really love his
family and i would like to move close to
them too but it is it just
and the good thing about it with his job
with this covet
is the teleworking opportunities have
really it doesn't limit us now where we
can live and he can still maintain you
can have roots anywhere and still and
still be able to do the job
yes yeah i i think all of a sudden uh
angela this this is no longer a money
call this is a marriage call and you all
need to just sit down and meet in the
middle he likes he likes some freedom to
roam let's get him some land pay cash
for it where he can roam and hunt and
fish or whatever it is you guys talked
about but you want to drop anchor and
you need to drop anchor and so you guys
need to sit down as a married couple and
go let's decide
he needs to know that you
uh don't feel safe
uh emotionally not knowing where you
want to land you want to land you want
to nest you want to
to settle
the difference maybe get it get us a
single family somewhere and get an rv so
you can guys can take off for there we
go you guys got plenty of money in the
back you got half a million dollars just
two of you get build a little house and
it's a nice asset it's going to
appreciate this land and george it's a
great point then you guys can drive
around and when you get tired of driving
around with each other then go back to
the house and you have home there you go
h-o-m-e i love it well angela it's a
good problem to have most of america is
like i wish i had angela's problem half
a million dollars don't know what to do
with it
isn't that true good for you by the way
look at that diligence you hear that ken
they would just say you know what we had
we got money and we put it to use we
saved it up we didn't go spend it on a
bunch of toys we just saved it up and
look at them now what's your position on
those tiny homes that you can drag
around are those basically mobile homes
still yeah they're they're just hipster
mobile homes so they don't appreciate no
ah okay that's what i thought if you've
got tons of money to blow and you just
want to have some fun make an airbnb
live there for a while that's fine i'm
not mad they look cool on those little
hd it's really cool i would fit great in
a tiny home so i've looked into it you
would you'd have plenty of room in a
tiny home oh boy hey it's been fun that
puts this hour in the books our thanks
to ben hill our producer kelly daniel
associate producer and phone screener
and you america thanks for tuning in
we'll be back with you before you know
it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money and your purpose
and your career i'm george campbell
joined today by my colleague ken coleman
host of the ken coleman show
best-selling author and all-around great
guy ken it's a pleasure to have you on
thank you george again we've been
hanging out a lot lately we have we have
today i i felt like it was time to bring
a little fall to the ramsay show with
that with the vest yeah
yeah the teams have a little bit of fun
with me uh today on the ken coleman show
they were giving me a little bit of hard
time you know like asking if i was going
to cut down some trees later you clearly
haven't chopped a lot of trees in your
day no if you've ever uh if i ever get
the privilege to meet you all if you
shake my hand you'll see that there's
not no moisture analysis no no now see
see you had to say that
no i don't moisturize my hands
all right america call in and let me
know if you think moisturizer is okay i
think more men need to be moisturizing
no no woman wants to touch that crusty
leathery hand
all right i i gotta tell you george
there's no way that the majority of
americans think that dudes need to be
moisturizing their hands i might ask
stacey coleman on my phone or friend i
guarantee you stacy's going to go no
i want to feel like i'm touching ken's
hands i resign i resign from this
conversation okay let's do what we do i
guess not best but pretty good uh taking
calls from you all triple eight eight
two five five two two five the phone
lines are open and they're waiting for
you katie joins us in charlotte north
carolina katie welcome to the ramsay
show
hey thank you absolutely how can we help
um yeah i was calling so we um
my husband and i are in our mid-30s and
we have three little kids um and he is
looking into going back to school
and we've been following
through y'all's baby steps we started
saving for our kids college
um
and him going back to school wasn't
necessarily always on the horizon but we
have saved up a good bit
in hopes to
get a rental property um
but based on our income we would qualify
for
fafsa but because we have money saved up
it's knocking us out of the bracket to
be able to qualify for that
so we don't want to do student loans but
we're kind of trying to figure out what
is a good way to do that or should that
money go towards school
so what was driving this decision for
him to go back to school is it a career
change is it an income thing yeah
a career change what's he moving into
um he would like to go back for
accounting
what's he doing now
uh he works at the police department
so does he need to get a four-year
degree or two years what's what does he
actually need
um for what he would eventually like to
get to it would definitely be a
four-year um so he has a two-year degree
at this point that he he would like a
four-year so he's got to get two more
years done
yeah is the plan to do that part-time
online while he's working
yes okay
how much is that looking to cost
um the
well he actually looking to do it
full-time online um but it looks like
it'll be about six to seven thousand a
semester
okay so round up we're looking at 28
grand oh no no no no no uh you're doing
two years
yep yes about 24 25 24 25 okay
um
where's the income coming in when he
goes full time as a student online
um we will both still be working so he's
working full-time while going to school
full-time oh wow okay all right so he
won't have a life for two years
we'll be busy for sure yeah okay all
right i got it but you've got money set
aside you said because uh for a rental
property that you guys are wanting to
get into
how much money set aside
uh we have about almost 40 right now oh
great
and are you able to cash flow school
without touching the 40.
or would you need to dip into that
um we would need to dip into that okay
yeah i think the priority here is to
have him graduate debt-free i think the
rental property is a great dream but it
needs to be put on hold until he's
finished with this education
okay so it's okay to say hey i know this
was allocated towards the rental
property but really this is going to
help us go to school debt free and the
rental property might be you know two
years down the road after that but have
you paid for your primary residence
uh no we still have
about half of it left okay okay
i would encourage you guys to pay off
the mortgage first and then get into
rental property and when you do do it
with cash i know that's going to slow
you down this might be a you know a five
ten year plan instead of the two-year
plan but i don't want to see you guys
strapped with a mortgage and then the
rental property mortgage and then you
can't find a renter and the school
situation's in flux so i want you to
finish out the school debt free and
focus on paying down that mortgage are
you guys in baby step six otherwise
um yes okay great so you're already
investing you've got the fully funded
emergency fund you're saving for those
three kids for their college yeah yep
how much how much more katie are you
guys projecting that your husband's
gonna make once he gets the accounting
degree and then he gets into the field
um we're hoping
it be i guess about like a third more
than he's making currently okay great
all right
well you know i listen i i i don't think
that you disagree but i want to make
sure that you hear what george is saying
that
doing it the way he said to do it is
going to take a little longer but the
impact is going to be so much bigger for
you guys financially down the line okay
you guys are in great shape do you know
how many people call the ken coleman
show every day that wish they had 40
grand in the bank to be able to cash
flow
uh their husband
changing careers and then have some left
over it's a lot right so you guys are in
great shape be patient patience is this
wonder drug
i'm just going to tell you all right
yeah we are the easiest to be
right it's horrible it's absolutely
horrible um
i'm gonna do a little mini sermonette
george okay but the good news is
there'll be no altar call or an offering
okay this is kind of this is kind of
don't take my money i'm the only one in
here ken these are the kind of sermons
people like
in our world we have glamorized
persistence
right
get up hustle hustle hustle hustle and
and that's very important but there is
no long-term persistence you will burn
out whether the goal is to get debt free
lose weight
get healthy in your relationships get a
great gig and a job and do work you love
i don't care what the objective is
persistence
absent of patience
will run out that was good tweet today
so here's why
i can get up and go go go hustle hustle
hustle hustle hustle but if i'm not
building the muscle and the discipline
of waiting and waiting for it to pay off
then i won't stay with it
because we humans are creatures of
progress right we want it now and it's
been exacerbated by the technology and
the digital age and we can get
everything right now like our kids i
need it now i need now well we all have
that but the reality is anything worth
getting
is a journey and there's a struggle
and you will not stay with it if you
don't learn the discipline of patience i
persist there's tension because i gotta
wait on it but learning to wait on it is
what keeps me coming back gives me the
ability to show up the next day and the
next day and the next day patience
it's the wonder drug right there keep
reaching pastor ken coleman bringing it
today on the ramsay show more of it
coming up
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by my pal ken
coleman
listen we had a big week last week a
huge launch
the future documentary out now if you
aren't strapped with student loan
payments the odds are you know someone
who is millions of people are putting
their lives on hold they can't buy a
house or have kids because they are
stuck or even worse they're waiting and
waiting and waiting for the government
to save them with student loan
forgiveness what a joke two percent
rate
on that student loan forgiveness from
the public's service loan forgiveness
program our team produced a brand new
documentary feature full-length film
borrowed future and it is out now it
uncovers the dark side of the student
loan industry and exposes how the system
is built to work against you you'll see
dave ramsey weigh in on the epic failure
otherwise known as the student loan
program along with featured interviews
from industry insiders and thought
leaders like seth godin seth fratman and
dr john deloney we're coming at this
hard folks we're taking big swings at
the student loan problem with the goal
to arm parents and students across the
country with the truth and here's the
truth
you don't have to take out loans to get
a college education you can be a student
without a student loan you can graduate
debt-free and avoid the predatory
student loan industry borrowed future is
available to watch now you can find it
on apple tv amazon prime video google
play or borrowed future.com let me also
throw in here that
you may not even need
the traditional college education whoa
ken you just blew some people's minds i
know i know here i go again and and
disclaimer i'm not anti-college
education however let me give a two-part
question for you parents out there and
those of you who are trying to decide
all right i'm thinking about career
pivot do i need a new degree to get
where i want to go two-part question
really simple here we go the first one
is
is a degree the only way
to get where i want to go the only way
second question is is the degree the
best way to get where i want to go folks
this is mind-numbingly simple
but if the answer is yes to the only way
lawyer doctor okay
if the answer is
it is the best way okay there's still a
way to do it there's still a way to plan
there's still a way to save there's
still a way to cash flow your way
through it uh but this i this this idea
that
the only way to career success is
through a degree
um is the is the byproduct of a
marketing message that has been crammed
down our throats
for going on about 50 years
um and and so be mature enough
mom and dad to uh
be okay talking to your kid and helping
your kid figure out what they want to do
and if a degree isn't the way the only
way get over it nobody cares
nobody cares by the way i love that
question when you ask somebody was the
last time you went to a doctor or some
professional services that required a
degree and you say to them did you have
you asked the person where they got
their degree like last time you were in
the dentist chair did you go hey real
quick before you do the old scrape uh
i'd like to see your diploma like nobody
does that
it's just art on the wall nobody
gives a crud where you went to college
yep you're the only person that cares
it's a pride thing right unless you're
on the football team i don't care
i like football so i'm gonna cheer for
school but if i was like i don't care
where you at school nobody unless you're
a football player nobody or basketball
or a major sport nobody cares where
you're with school
nobody we've got to make some sound
decisions here based on logic
it's about a ticket yeah education could
be an online certification you know uh
could be an apprenticeship it's the
education is what do i need to learn
to be able to actually do what i want to
do that's the simplicity of it doesn't
necessarily need to be a degree so i
wanted to put that in there because
that's part of what's driving this
crisis as well is the cultural pressure
that says if if my kid doesn't leave
high school and go get a degree he or
she is a loser
and that's a lie from the pit of hell
and was i clear on that pretty clear
okay yeah more of that in uh in borrowed
future go check it out 88 minute
documentary borrower future.com is the
place to go all right let's go to the
phone lines open phone lines triple
eight eight two five five two two five
dale is in pueblo colorado dale welcome
to the ramsay show
thanks for taking my call guys sure how
can we help you got a couple questions
for ken here real quick
i recently had a bad horseback riding
accident i lost both my legs
oh dale i'm so sorry
sorry
that's okay
dale how long ago was that
about two years oh man
i'm so sorry
so i'm trying to find a career yeah i
can go to
yeah
dale what were you doing uh
for work prior to the accident american
people
you are leading leading
leading a team of people
farming home industry yeah
okay
okay
and have you been on a physical
disability are you on disability right
now
just recently
just recently got there
yeah okay
um the reason i'm asking this is i want
to see what our maybe our moves are here
uh what kind of financial shape are you
in
bad
wow
dude what kind of what kind of debt do
you have
what is it well i don't haven't heard
anything that i don't have debt it's not
a problem it's just matter i can barely
afford to live okay what are your
disability payments right now what are
you getting in on a monthly basis
thirteen hundred
okay thirteen hundred are you living by
yourself living with someone what's your
what's your
with my fiance it's causing little
problems there to yourself
okay all right
um
if the fiance was not in the picture
uh in your area of colorado what would
rent cost you
oh about 900 a month okay so there's
hardly any margin there at all
so yeah we definitely need to get income
um
are you
like for the 1300s i like to make the
disability
i'm sorry
i can't make an additional 1300 a month
on top of my disability and i have to
suffer any loss of insurance or okay
anything like that all right so with the
injury being two years ago are you uh
able to function in and out of society
just our in our wheelchair what are you
what are you what's your i walk every
day oh you do
i still walk every day i farm every day
i
still have horses and
stuff i still ride horses okay now wait
a second three times a week okay so so
obviously this is a traumatic injury but
physically you are not limited now
i am limited to weight picking out that
i'm limited to i can't pick up over 40
pounds i understand that but if i heard
you correctly you said that you used to
lead people you were in a management
position prior to the accident
yes well dale
while i am grieving for you and this is
incredibly traumatic
and i understand your emotion what's
keeping you from getting back if you're
riding horses and walking all over the
place and being physically like of
what's keeping you from getting back
into the workforce and leading people
again you lost your legs you did not
lose the ability to lead
well i think there's a lot of things
going on that just uh i know
society doesn't look at disabilities the
way they used to i understand
and by the way dale i'm not minimizing
that what i'm trying to get you to
identify is what's really holding you
back
well the kidney failure he'll hold me
back too i'm on dialysis now three days
a week
okay all right so there okay i was not
aware of that i didn't catch that so
yeah so you're limited um into how much
time you can work because of the
dialysis
yeah i can rearrange that a little bit
if i need to rearrange the evenings or
weekends or whatever i'm not opposed to
that dale have you been seeing all right
here's the deal we only got about a
minute and i don't want to rush this but
here's the thing i think there's two
things you've got to do and i think you
need to be doing them consecutively
if you've already seen counseling you
need to continue to to get some
counseling for the grief and the trauma
you've got some relationship issues
going on with the fiance you have got to
get healthy emotionally and you got to
get with a professional if you've not
done counseling you've got to do that
simultaneously i want you to try to work
your dialysis schedule out
to where you can work more hours and i
want you to get back in it there are a
lot of people who'd love to give you a
second chance because you're a hero
you've overcome an unbelievable
devastating injury and you haven't
forgot how to lead people and i'm going
to suggest to you dale listen
that you loving on people and leading
people
will do wonders for you getting healthy
again you need greater income
to get that spine straighter again and
believe in yourself that you can in fact
recover you can in fact do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm george campbell joined today by ken
coleman this is the ramsey show and in
the lobby of ramsay solutions on the
debt-free stage we've got lashante from
washington d.c and i understand you are
debt-free i am i love to hear it
i'm so excited so what area do you live
i live in maryland okay so but i'm about
10 minutes from d.c all right i'll take
it so how much have you paid off
400 a total of
and seventy thousand but in the last
five years four hundred and five
thousand
wow okay and how long did this take
405 000 has been the last five years
okay so we'll call it five years 405.
and what was your range of income during
this time
um i started uh at 85 000 and now i'm at
185.
i want to hear the story on that where
did that jump in income come from
um i am an instructional systems
designer
but i'm also a landlord
and i also work part-time
so talking about working like no one
else oh my goodness this one here works
look jew you got three job titles that's
right that's incredible i got about six
yeah i just told you that you just only
told us three yeah okay wow very
impressive these whole lots of fabulous
can i just tell you that right now this
is gonna be good
i'm very impressed these numbers are
hurting my brain so what type of debt
was this 405 000
all real estate wow so i'll just rewind
for a second okay i met dave on the
radio in 2007. okay so that's when of
course you do your 1 000 emergency fund
you look at all your commercial debt all
your student loan debt
that was 65 000
and so once i cleared that out that took
me three years
then i started working on the real
estate stuff and that's been the last
five years wow so what kind of real
estate is this
uh my house
and i also owned a condo that i sold in
may whoa
unbelievable wow so you're totally crazy
you're the house and everything
everything look at you so what's what
real estate do you own now you have your
primary house just the house yeah
you are incredible but i'm looking
you're looking for something for some
investment i'm looking for something
else okay how do you have time to look
for anything with your six jobs and the
three you only told us i want to know
how much time you're squeezing out of
the 24 hours i have
you make time ken you know that oh
she just dropped that one for what
matters right
that was a pretty good serve over the
net and she just smoked it right by my
ear
so five years ago because you've heard
you've known about day for a long time
now five years ago though something
something happened what got you on this
journey so what i was able to do
i bought my house during the real estate
boom
that was in 2005.
and so i had a prepayment penalty
on my mortgage and so i wasn't able to
refinance or do anything for 10 years or
i was going to have to pay a penalty of
like 15 000. so in 2016 i was able to
get out of my penalty
refinance i refinanced for ten years and
i killed it in five whoo
i'm telling you
get in front of lashantay at your own
ask
so what were the sacrifices what did you
do obviously you had a lot of side jobs
here is that what did it for you what
were those sacrifices so in my home um i
have a town home i actually had a
contractor come in and i kind of have
this one of my friends calls it an
in-house in-law suite
and so i rent that out to young ladies
that move to the washington dc area you
know we're very transient area so always
someone coming to go to school always
someone coming to get a new job
and so
my
my space that i have
it's by word of mouth
everybody knows that that space is there
and so when my tenant moves out people
say lashantay is the space available yes
it's available and so someone else moves
in so that's been a part of
my process as well wow and during my
when i had my condo i also had a tenant
there wow so you had some rental income
coming in on top of some of these side
jobs absolutely wow what was the most
lucrative side job for you
it may be the one that i'm doing right
now
are you trying to be secretary i monitor
data centers oh interesting you monitor
data centers yeah okay all right
so like do you sleep at all
sometimes
i'm sleeping while i'm here in nashville
how about that that's good all right
have earned it what would you say is the
key to getting out of debt
the gotta juana
okay you gotta want to sacrifice
sleep that was good you gotta want to
sacrifice i'm wrong i'm a speller
you gotta wanna sacrifice
energy you gotta wanna budget you gotta
wanna say no to yourself and you gotta
wanna say yes
to your future i love that wow all right
we're gonna stay on this theme because
you're preaching now you're getting
warmed up you're riling up ken over here
i'm gonna put the ball on the tee for
you here i love the gotta wanna yeah by
the way if you're keeping score at home
that's g-o-t-t-a gotta
wanna
w-a-n-a that's fantastic that right
there will preach gotta wanna but here's
what i wanna know what was the big one
of driving this what's driving you
what's your big why behind the wanna
there's a couple number one legacy
um i was born to very young parents
louis and toyah davis they had me when
they were 18. wow so the way um
when i was presented with college
there was no funds for college so i did
have to take out some loans and so i
just wanted to
have something for
my niece or my nephew or my own children
or some children that i impact their
lives and so that will be the legacy
that i leave and also for my mom and dad
how proud of you are they
they're so proud of me we were supposed
to come here in august but hurricane
rita
kept us away and they would have been
right here
but i got a second chance because i came
to business boutique all right all right
and so i'm here now so they'll be
looking at the replay i love it so do
you have any cheerleaders along the way
yes uh one is right here in the audience
her name is johnny's hair is she filming
me right now
she is yeah yes we met in grad school in
2004 at george washington university
and so we have been neck and neck
she also
is a landlord she also is an i.t guru so
we've been able to compare notes she's
also going through her debt-free journey
and it's just a blessing to be able to
have friends
that are doing what you do yeah huge wow
that's incredible so can i ask how old
you are oh george only because i want to
inspire so many people out there oh boy
is it dangerous yes it's not dangerous
okay
i'd like you to guess first and then oh
yeah george here's the thing i'm trying
jordan mike hold on i'm not gonna let my
colleague step into this oh i was so
excited no george you never never
34. oh i love you forever i am 44. oh i
was close my heart is racing
my heart is racing you are an
inspiration i mean you're a baby step
seven yeah nothing's gonna stop you no a
lot of people out there have a lot of
excuses and they got all the butts in
the world but she's got a gotta wanna
she's gotta gotta
i just wanna know if part of the gotta
wanna wear those shoes you're wearing
always
i'm always go into the room right and
fabulous even even without the sparkly
here's
heels she's got enough sparkle in her
personality
you are just a joy and have such an
amazing personality you've just made my
day yes so let's get to this we've got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
you're already living that you told us
that was your big why and now you get to
live that out we also have a copy of the
total money makeover hopefully you can
inspire another friend to get on this
debt-free journey along the way and pay
that forward all right you ready for
this i am this is the moment we've all
been waiting for all right it's lashante
from washington d.c area 405 thousand
dollars paid off in five years making 85
up to 185
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
so something i used to sing to myself
i'm debt free
i'm debt free
no more chains holding me
once was lost god set me free
thank the lord i'm debt-free
i'm dead
[Applause]
touchdown there it
is she pulled us in with a little
singing and then went to the screaming
wow fantastic what a voice yes two
that's what baby step seven does for you
i don't think that'll do it for me i
won't sing that great what an
inspiration kevin fantastic thank you so
much for being here for the ramsey show
coming up
[Music]
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast joined
today by my colleague ken coleman host
of the ken coleman show
our blinds question of the day is coming
up find out for yourself why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from luna in kentucky i'm going to
college for accounting and i have a debt
free full ride i currently work in a
factory to help pay the to help pay the
bills while i'm in school i find myself
hating people the older i get
and i'm only 31 boy that took a dark
turn fast george wow i didn't see that i
didn't read that ahead of time that's
probably kind of best kind of caught me
off guard there wow only 31 and hating
people
i don't mean to sound bitter too late
but people are just aggravating to deal
with after a while i can handle them in
small doses but it's more of a headache
than i care to express to anyone out
loud is accounting a good path for me or
is there a better career for someone
like me okay
so luna i appreciate the question i love
the raw honesty
but this is not a career question
this is a
emotional
personal
health
question and what i mean by that is
if you are finding yourself hating
people the older you get we want to get
to the bottom of what's causing this
not no longer an irritant but an
abhorrent
disgust for people that's a you think
see you're the common denominator and
all these other people if there's a
common denominator
around this hate it's you
why i really sincerely am not being
sarcastic here i i think you've got to
get
uh some counseling and discover what it
is that's irritating you
i think you're using hate a little too
freely here i'm gonna go ahead and
assume you really don't hate people but
i could see that people irritate you and
maybe suck the life out of you but again
you're the common denominator i would
focus on what it is that seems to
irritate you and you've got to get some
tools
mental and emotional tools and
strategies that a counselor can help you
with
because there is no career
that i could suggest that's going to
heal this issue the issue
is you
and your
irritation with people we got to fix
that
then the rest of it takes care of itself
yeah that's an interesting
accounting here and uh in accounting you
have to deal with people
well you may i mean you could say i mean
i could sit here and brainstorm all i
want to work from home and do some
things digitally there's some careers
where you're not going to be around
people as much but that's not going to
solve the issue that's not going to take
care of the problem yeah i appreciate
the honesty some healthy relationships
in her life because my assumption is
people may not being
they don't like being around her i'm
guessing you don't have too too much of
a chipper personality if that's the
attitude she's not mrs sunshine i can
tell you that but you know again there's
some pain there and i'm not making light
of that it's just you've got to get get
healthy yeah and back to her question is
accounting a good path for me is there a
better career path for someone like me i
think accounting could be a great career
path but we've got to deal with this
issue i'm not going to answer that it's
like this is not a career path question
it's like sure go do accounting but if
you if people hate you so much
um
well you know maybe you get that office
down in the basement like the guy in
office space with the red stapler
that's a safe place it's kind of the
future for you that's no fun for anybody
well thanks for the question luna we're
going to the phone lines now jennifer
joins us in portland oregon jennifer
welcome to the ramsay show
hello
so my issue is we have a 2013 dodge
journey with over 140 000 miles and it
has a lot of issues but it's still
running
and my husband wants to trade it in
for a newer vehicle with less issues
and i don't
see the benefit of that because it's
still working and running
and i don't want to go further into debt
because we're still on baby step two
okay what kind of debt are you guys
paying off right now
uh we have one credit card a couple of
doctor bills and the biggest thing is
his student loans
how much debt total
a little over 40 42
000 and what's your household income
right now it just bumped up to 70 000.
okay and i'm hoping to start work now
that our kids are back in full-time
school
okay so that will bring the income up
a little bit yeah okay so
trading in the car and the issues that's
one thing but what i would do if i was
in your shoes is just start a sinking
fund for a car you can pay in cash for
is he wanting to go into debt for a car
yeah he wants to get like a 20 000
vehicle and i just don't see the benefit
of that i mean yes it's newer but we're
still getting a used vehicle with
possibly more issues what's his logic of
of getting a 20 000 vehicle
i honestly don't know he thinks that
since it'll be newer there will be less
issues so he's sick of the problems on
the dodge and he's going man i don't
want to deal with any more issues if we
get an expensive car there'll be less
issues
yeah
has he been on board with you here
his biggest fear is that at 170 000
supposedly miles
basically is like
the time
okay
tick
30 000 miles away
yeah so can you not save up for a year
or two in a sinking fund and get out of
this debt and then get a car with cash
i think we could if we really stuck our
nose to the grindstone and did that
but he's not on board are you on board
with the baby steps in general because
it sounds like there's some disagreement
oh yes
he's totally on board with it and we're
actually hosting a financial peace
university class starting next week
wow well okay so jennifer so here so i
think once this class starts he'll still
realize hopefully hopefully but here's
what i think you've got to do because
he's on board can i suggest that you
cast a little vision
so when somebody casts vision right
their their vision casting
by definition is about showing a better
future right this is the future we're
headed to yeah and i think he's on board
with the baby steps but the vision he's
having a hard time with is
we got to have a more dependable car and
he's starting to go oh boy we've got a
law of diminishing returns here so i'm
going to try to change up the baby steps
and do it my way
what you got to do is instead of
debating him on that i think you got to
cast a vision to say hey before this
thing hits the 170 000 mile like don't
try to change the terms with him stay in
his narrative and go i here's a plan
on paper with my new job because i'm
going to be able to go back full time
with that increased income we can
replace this car like george is saying
while still moving forward on the baby
steps he's on board with that i just
think you got to show him
literally
how you get there
that would be my approach because then
there's no disagreement there's no
trying to you know knock his logic down
it's just like okay i get it
we have 30 000 miles before you think
man we've hit the law of diminishing
returns on this car here's how we cash
flow and replace this car and don't go
backwards i think that's the vision
okay i can do that i know you can like i
can hear i can hear you got a little
juice don't you're like oh no that's a
different blog game and so i think
that's what you do thank you all right
now listen you gotta put a little sugar
and spice on that okay once you show him
the plan then you gotta go come on baby
please please maybe make his favorite
dessert please do this for me i'm i'm
locked arms with you my income's going
up we can do this
and we can if we just stick our nose to
the grindstone all right i love it all
we got to do here is make that sinking
fun happen because we know that the car
is not going to be an emergency when it
goes out we know it's on its way out in
a few years but not tomorrow so start
saving up on the side for this you can
you don't have to stop the debt free
journey once you get some income coming
in you can get rid of this debt in a
year
with your income if you're living on
half of what you make you can do this
thing that's 42k the credit card the
medical debt the student loan it's not
going to be in your life a year from now
and then you can start dreaming about
that 20 000 car and save up and pay cash
for it but especially if you're going to
lead financial peace university for the
love do not get a car payment while
you're leading financial peace
university that feels icky ken i don't
like that one bit yeah yeah it's a since
it's definitely a conflict conflict of
interest you know it's funny though
george it's like just because you
level up
ten thousand dollars or fifteen thousand
dollars doesn't mean that cars are gonna
have problems oh yeah
plenty of uh twenty thousand dollar cars
with
twenty thousand dollar
type repairs here it gets very expensive
very quickly
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books our thanks to producer ben
hill associate producer and phone
screener kelly daniel my colleague ken
coleman and you america for listening in
this has been another hour of the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and money
and purpose and calling and career and
all of the questions you need answered
i'm george campbell joined today by my
pal ken coleman and we are taking your
calls and it's a free one triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight five two five wait what i did it
wrong ken you just forgot a two triple
eight eight two five five two two five
there it is it happens it's simple but
it's complex yeah it's burned to my
brain and we are taking your calls and
we're going to open this hour with our
friend scott in indianapolis indiana
scott welcome to the ramsay show
thank you uh my wife and i have
not necessarily disagreement but just
trying to get
guidance on
how much for a new car is is appropriate
to spend okay talk us through this
what's your financial situation
well uh we're debt-free and we'd be
paying with cash
um
and uh we generally drive cars into the
ground so i've had mine for 12 years
and uh bought it two years uh it was two
years old when i bought it and
uh looking at uh stepping up a bit but a
lot's changed in the world in 12 years
since we've bought a car
so just trying to get a handle on
how much to spend what are you looking
at
well
i'd like to get a alfa romeo whoa
hey now good shot
you know it's a pretty car
um
now i currently drive a five series bmw
okay
but i got the tax uh appraisal and it's
worth like four thousand bucks now and
like well you know maybe i need a new
car because i've had this one for 12
years how much is the alpha romeo you're
looking at
i'd be about 90. oh
okay all right and you've got the cash
to pay for it
yes
where are you guys at in the baby steps
you've been following that plan you said
you're debt-free do you have a paid for
house
yes yes so uh
uh i first heard dave
in 1998
wow and i've been following the plan
since then so we have a net worth of
about three and a half million
well that changes the equation my friend
way to go and what's your income
currently uh
yeah probably about five a year 500 000
a year
yeah yeah and so your wife is saying 90
000 because you've never you've lived
like no one else
i mean
you you're you're it's unbelievable so
what's the disagreement
she just doesn't like the price tag
she's saying it's too much
well yeah i mean you know our first
house was only
like uh
200 and uh you know and we've been
looking at cars and a lot of the cars
don't cost what they cost 12 years ago
right brandon this is a really nice car
but she's emotionally grappling with the
fact that a car could cost ninety
thousand dollars and you want it
yeah i i think that's it what's the
number that she's okay with if it's if
90 is a bit much in her eyes what's the
number she goes i'm fine with this
number
well yeah i'm trying in case she hears
this later i don't want to
hear it from her but you know i spent 30
on the last car and so she's like well
why not it's been 35. and but that
doesn't go as far as it used to no and
it's a percentage of our net worth you
know we're worth like 10x what we were
yes
on the ramsey side you guys are in in
amazing shape and there's no problem
with getting this 90 000 car but this is
not really a financial question this is
more of a relational question how do i
get my wife on the same page
so that i can get the car
yeah i'm not even necessarily trying to
you know it's just you know how you know
we didn't grow up with this kind of
money right so uh you know on one hand
it the intellectual side of it's pretty
straightforward because i can do ratios
and why not but well you've listened to
dave a long time george you can refresh
him let's just play out the the
percentages
yeah you've got multi-million dollar net
worth and you're saying hey can i spend
a tiny tiny fraction of that on a car
that we're paying cash for and is well
under half of our income
in that scenario it's hard to look at
the math and go wow this is an
outrageous expense but i get to your
wife she remembers the old days and
she's going man that's way too much to
be spending on a car but you guys have
worked you've sacrificed you've lived
like no one else and now is the part
where you get to live like no one else
how old are you
scott um
uh about 50
just turned 50. it's hard to say out
loud i know i could tell you were like
about 50.
um that's like
it's all we were nine we're like i'm
nine and a half thank you very much just
rounding yeah you know what if you said
your wife's fine and it's not a getting
her on board issue it's just you wanted
to double check your percentages well
you got your answer i'd buy the car
all right well uh what does she get out
of the deal
well i'm trying to get her a nicer car
if i could give her a
land rover or something but uh hers is
not as many miles on his mind she she
drives the kids around so i don't mind
what i drive but i think if we're going
to get something new we should get
something good well let her dream a
little bit you guys have done so well
does she like buying stuff or is she
very still very diligent and frugal and
says ah that's that's a waste
yeah i mean really the only thing we
splurge on is trips because we like to
get the kids out and travel but we just
don't spend a lot
take her on a nice trip yeah i mean have
you driven this uh this alfa romeo have
you taken it out for a spin
well i i i i will i haven't yet
i'm very weary of car fever so
well that's been inoculated against car
fever i get it and i think you've been
very disciplined i'm actually going to
recommend that you know why don't you go
out and drive a 60 000 car
you know
i understand the 90 000 alpha romeo and
the percentages and you're there but you
know just try several things
um
but you don't have anything to be afraid
of making the kind of money you're
making and you're debt free and the
percentages here say it's good but you
know go drive the thing you know
they'll let you do it you got the cash
you can show them it's right there in
the bank
um drive a fee drive a few other amazing
things get it out of your system a
little bit and then decide what you want
to do but you know you've done the right
things and now at almost 50 uh or you
are 50. i can't remember what he said
you know you uh
you've earned it and uh
you two got to be on the same page
though you know what i mean like
agreed yeah and that's the key i think
as long as you do that um that's
fantastic yeah great question scott
fantastic job you guys have put yourself
in a face i was hoping he had a story
for us george well he'll come back he'll
call us back you know those cars by the
way there's a reason they cost what they
cost what is that high performance is
that it i always thought it was great
branding and marketing no no uh
for father's day about five years ago
stacy and the kids surprised me
and i got to do seven laps on a road
course
in a lamborghini we're talking a
racetrack here oh yeah real racetrack
lamborghini diablo okay
there's a difference i was terrified and
the instructor's in the car with me so
he's like look it's one of those fakes
dude he's like this is gonna feel like
you're gonna flip the car but it will
not flip you gotta trust me i'm like i
don't trust you man
i mean the speed and the power in these
cars how fast did you take it uh
honestly george i was so focused on the
road i never looked you never looked
down i listen was it so exhilarating and
terrifying at the same time was it 100
oh yeah on the straightaways i got it up
to 200. very impressive
well you guys like your cars i'll give
you that
but do it with cash people do it the
right way do not go into debt and do it
like scott did completely debt-free way
to go with a multi-million dollar net
worth half america's going yawn scott
buy the car
do it man
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
zipruder.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at zip recruiter dot
com slash ken that's ziprecruiter.com
slash ken sign up today absolutely free
and let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman it's a free call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five
if you're a parent you probably know
college has gotten crazy expensive and
if you've seen our documentary borrowed
future you know student loans are not
the answer they're a trap and they've
buried millions of people under a
mountain of debt
on the other hand scholarships and
financial aid can help pay for college
and if you've got a kid going to college
they need to go after that free money
with all they've got
but because there's no way to know if
those will come through for you you need
a bigger plan to pay for college esas
and 529s are where it is at these are
college savings accounts that you invest
money in and it grows tax-free for
college expenses
esas and 529s have different rules
around age income and your investment
options so you'll want to talk to an
expert to understand what's right for
you we recommend working with a smart
investor pro they're investing
professionals we trust in your area that
have a heart of a teacher that's what
you need to look for you can text the
word college to 33789 and we'll help you
find a smartvestor pro in your area that
way you can help your kids graduate
debt-free and have a firm foundation for
their future again text college to 33789
let's go to the phone lines this hour we
are joined by zach in huntington west
virginia zack welcome to the ramsay show
hello hey how can we help
yeah um
i was calling because
i'm interested in
going going to college for some stuff
i've already got a bachelor's degree but
i have a scholarship for a master of
arts in
christian studies and
afterwards i was thinking about
pursuing a doctorate in
in divinity
but i'm running into some issues me and
my wife are okay we're on the same page
about the master's degree but
my wife seems to think that um
getting a doctorate is kind of it's kind
of a waste of money because we want to
pay for our kids to go to school too so
i was wanting to know is is that really
something that someone should pursue
should i pursue that
if there's not really any financial gain
but i just kind of feel like i want to
what do you mean by want to here just
like is it a pride thing would just feel
nice to say hey i've got a phd i've done
something
i've always wanted to get a doctorate
yeah um
it what but but it's not just financial
gain but professional gain right so what
what are what are you what are you uh
purposing to do in your career
i want to teach in seminary and be a
pastor all right so
it comes down to the two questions i
like to put to people is it the only way
for you to do that is it the best way
what's the answer to both of those
questions
would be a pastor no no you know i
wouldn't need that but really to teach
at any seminary i would probably need
at least a a doctor to some kind of
course
so hired on full time right so you and
your wife are going okay we've got our
shared goals
and it sounds like to me you just got to
get to a point where you go
we've got some other goals for the kids
and we're on the same page there and so
we got to take care of that and then
down the road i can cash flow the phd
once we take care of some other
priorities is that what i'm hearing
i think so yeah well it just comes down
to priorities you saying not
now
does it mean no
and it sounds like she's going i don't
think it's the right move right now do
you agree with her right now
right yeah yeah right now i i was
thinking you know maybe 10 years from
now but it was kind of
i wasn't she seemed a bit firmer on it
so i wasn't sure whether you know well i
mean it comes down to whether you agree
with her or not i think you agree with
her not now down the line once we take
care of other priorities yes seems like
she's probably on board with that as
well correct
yeah i think so
well we we need to know so i mean this
is a conversation to say hey and again
uh when cash
is in a place where you can do it
because you want to
great
but
yeah you know if there's a difference
between want to and well i do want to
move from the pastorate and eventually
teach on a seminary level well then
that's i have to i've got to do that to
get that seminary teaching position but
down the line so i think it's you all
sitting together and going hey what are
our shared goals the shared vision about
our life including kids
and then eventually financially um
professionally what are our goals let's
look at all those buckets together get
on the same page and then um
you know it's not really a no and i
think when you're having the
conversation with her right now i think
you feel like you're hearing no
and i think what you've got to do is
change that too
not now not yet make sense
okay yeah i think so yeah i think you're
right yeah because here's the deal
no feels final george yeah
think about it i mean in any area of our
life when we hear a no it feels very
final that door's closed
and and that's what he's feeling
but the doctorate is not seminary is not
an mdiv it's not a never it's not right
now big difference
good call there jared is in phoenix
arizona jared welcome to the ramsey show
hi how you guys doing today great how
can we help oh yes my mother is gifting
us sixty thousand dollars and i'm just
curious on what you guys's opinion is to
what i should or could do with this
money wow that's nice of her is there
any reason behind it or she just has
extra cash and wants to bless you with
this
um grandma had passed away in march and
left mom 1.3
wow
that's a blessing there
so and she's given you a portion of this
yes sir out of a kindness of her heart
yes okay how old are you
uh 34 you're 34 where are you at
financially do you have any debt
uh no i mean babysit four five and six
uh oh about 200 on the house that we
just purchased okay that's great
and so uh are you you have a wife
yes sir have you talked to her about
this money
yes we have what's her thoughts on it
um
no about the same as mine not too sure
because we're investing 15
uh we're doing the
investing for the kids college the house
mortgage is less than 25 percent of our
income it's a 500 000 house we only have
200 on it so it's kind of like do we
just dump it on the house do we invest
it yeah if you don't have any other
short-term goals if there's no other
short-term goals like hey we need to
upgrade the car or we've got a home
repair we've got to do
um you're already doing all those baby
steps i would just let this speed up
your baby step six and get this house
paid off
okay
is that what you guys were thinking or
do you have any other thoughts
yeah we were thinking that we were also
thinking about getting rid of our
electric bill and going solar but i
don't know about the roi on that and if
it's a good investment or
much about that yeah it's it's going to
take a while to roi on that so my if i'm
you i'm not i'm not taking that one i
know you're in you're in phoenix area
and solar is big there but it's still
very expensive and it'll still take
years to recoup that money i'd rather
see you have a no mortgage and then
maybe we can talk about solar if you're
going to stay in that house a while and
that's something you guys want to just
cash flow for fun but i want to see this
mortgage gone and i feel like with your
intensity at 34 you guys are doing
really well if there's no other
short-term goals i'm going ahead and
slapping down that mortgage and feeling
that progress ken yeah there jared i
love that you're trying to think about
saving money and efficiency and all that
but there it's not apples to apples
paying off that house is going to yield
so much more financial gain for you than
than turning your entire house into a
solar panel you know i mean it's a good
thing but there's ways to save money
it's not even close so don't get
distracted and again another wrong with
this but that's a distraction yeah you
know like well what if i did this and i
did the solar print no knock the house
out
way way better play yeah that's
incredible jared well we're rooting for
you call us back when that house is paid
off you guys are crushing it man yeah
that's awesome all right thank you
everybody i love it that's what i love
to see ken because i'm i'm on that
journey i'm a little younger than jared
but we have a big goal to pay off this
house and the way that it's going to set
up jared and his family to be you know
in his 30s with a paid for house crazy
no payments
they're gonna be able to do whatever
they want yeah yeah it's really
phenomenal it's a game changer and you
think about the amount of money that
you're saving
um there are other ways to like you know
all right let's get the house more
efficient and all that kind of stuff you
know what i mean yeah
that's what i love about the baby steps
it clearly says here's what to do next
with my money what is my next goal that
makes sense for my long-term financial
future yeah when you can filter it
through that framework it just lets
things lets things be a lot more clear
and where there's clarity there is
freedom yes i love it we've got more of
the show coming up give us a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
i'm george campbell he's ken coleman
this is the ramsay show
do
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm george campbell host of the fine
print and entree leadership podcast
joined today by ken coleman host of the
aptly named ken coleman show yeah we
spent hours and hours the creative
meetings must have been exhilarating
lots of dollars to come up with that i
love it we're taking your calls the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five and elizabeth joins us
in the washington dc area elizabeth
welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are you we are doing fantastic
we're happy to talk to you how can we
help
awesome yeah so my husband and i we are
currently finishing up baby well we're
on baby steps four five and six and we
currently live in bc we're renting an
apartment now
i think we lost you there
we have a 15 year mortgage on that
so i repeat that i heard up until you
have an apartment in dc
yes so we also have a home that we own
in dc right in atlanta with a 15-year
mortgage okay and so we have we have
tenants who have decided they don't want
to renew um moving forward and so now
we're debating on what our next step
should be so initially we were thinking
our first option was to just search for
another tenant have them sign a 12-month
lease and then use that extra money to
just go gazelle intense and pay off the
atlanta home within three years
and the second option is to sell the
house that we have in atlanta and
purchase a home in dc with the money
from the cell of the atlanta house now
the caveat with that though is that
we're not sure if we actually want to be
in bc within three years once we start
considering a family we might want to
move back to north carolina so
interesting that is where we're at so
you're not sure about planning roots in
dc quite yet it could be you said about
three years
yeah in about three years um so yeah i
mean i'm 29 my husband is 33 and we're
thinking that when we start to you know
talk about children and stuff like that
we'll want to be closer to our family
which is in atlanta cc is just really
expensive no in north carolina oh so
you'd be moving completely to north
carolina if you made this yeah so either
way
you will have no roots in atlanta
anymore
exactly tell me why you wouldn't sell
the home in atlanta let's come at it
from that because you called us you want
to know our thoughts but i want to know
what you were thinking and primarily i
want to know why you would not sell it
right now in atlanta
yeah so our thing is like it's still
like a newer home um we purchased it in
2018 and so like there's not really much
that really goes wrong with the house at
this point so at this point like having
tenants in and having them pay is like
you know it's just extra money and then
we were thinking another alternative to
that is even like possibly doing airbnb
and then just having a place to stay
whenever we go visit okay couple things
couple things i'm gonna jump in real
quick okay uh how much is the house
worth if you were to sell it
uh it would sell at 269 right now what
do you owe on it
160. okay and you said something at this
point i think you said at this point
twice
right now it's new and at this point
there's not a whole lot of upkeep well
before you know it you're starting to
have to deal with something and you're a
long way away
i know the atlanta area pretty well
i just don't i you know at this point
the market's as hot hot hot as it can be
if you were to sell this house right now
you pay it off and then you have some
money that you guys can then invest
while you're trying to figure out what
the next three four years is gonna look
like you're not moving to atlanta
doesn't sound like to me it sounds like
north carolina is in the future
i just don't know why you wouldn't sell
it um it to me you you fast forward your
financial goals so much by selling it
and pocketing the profit on it as
opposed to keeping it going and making a
little bit per month
right that's true okay that's exactly
what i needed to hear that was just kind
of a cash out baby
because we were we were at that so i
appreciate that and then when it comes
to purchasing a home in dc like do you
think we should you said just invest it
up until we get to that point or how
much would you be able to put down on a
home in dc after we sell this place in
atlanta
yeah so we were thinking just like 80
like the average house
here
is going around like four hundred
thousand for a new build so we would
just put those eighty thousand it's just
to me to me i'd sit tight i feel like
you guys because i just it doesn't sound
like to me you're a firm on when we're
going to north carolina you could change
your mind six months from now it sounds
like to me
yeah
so i wouldn't buy a place in dc george
would you do you have a lease right now
in dc
yeah we just renewed for another year
here okay what i would do is i'd sell
that house i'd park it in a high-yield
savings account for now to keep it
liquid in case like ken said you change
your mind in six months or a year after
this lease is over and you decide hey we
need this money you know for a down
payment for wherever we go so i would
keep it liquid and then if you decide
hey we're playing our roots in dc you
can take that money out and it will have
grown by a little bit it sounds like
you'd probably have close to six figures
in savings sitting there which is
totally fine if that's for short-term
goals
okay got it yeah awesome well thank you
yeah absolutely great stuff there ken
well you know you got a lot of nuances
yeah and well but this is a young couple
and i think this is the key
they're figuring out
as we speak they're literally going to
well we don't know if we're going to
stay in dc another two years three years
uh do we start the family then we move
back to north carolina and i get to just
tell you you know i've been on that side
you know just because we want to try to
start to have a family doesn't mean we
just wish it to happen yeah so i think
as a young couple staying as flexible as
possible
is what i would recommend flexibility is
king for a young couple because they're
they're still figuring it out you know
and so
um
i think though that there's this
pressure to oh we got to own a place or
we're wasting our money no you aren't
and getting out from underneath that
place in atlanta and making a profit
i mean they're already sitting on just
the 80 000 from the house or right at a
20 down payment
on something in the 400s flexibility is
the name of the game if you're a young
couple with no kids good word let's go
to hunter in hartford connecticut hunter
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how's it going great how can ken and
i help
uh so i've been following the baby steps
for quite a while i was pretty dumb when
i was young and i ended up racking up
about 90 000 in debt between credit card
in a car
so for about nine months i didn't go out
and do anything saved as much as
possible to pay it off
so
paid off my credit card paid off a lot
of my car and due to a kind of fluke
investment i now have 17 grand and i owe
about 24 on my car
so i'm trying to think if i should just
aside from the thousand dollar savings
put it towards my car so three months
from now
my car's paid off but in six months i'm
gonna be moving
so i don't know if i should keep that
money for
eventually when i move how much is this
move going to cost you
i'm not sure so i'm getting out of the
military and moving i'm not too sure
where yet and so that's where it's kind
of i don't know
well i don't think it's going to be a 17
000 move so maybe you just set aside
that thousand dollar um as a moving fund
because you know that's coming up
regardless and you slap 16 on this car
leaving you with eight left
yeah
and then you're going to get rid of that
without
yeah because i have about right now i'm
making about six
thousand dollars a month and my
operating cost is just above 2 000 so
i'm putting most of it into paying stuff
off heck yeah and and let's hunter you
got plenty of time to save up for a move
once you get an idea where you're going
you get a quote and and
let's say you have a three-month lead
time even in just your normal
three-month of operating expenses you've
got enough to be able to fund the move
yeah i think you can pay this car off
and then still save up for that money
within six months i absolutely think so
is that possible hunter
well that's 100 possible yeah i've been
i negotiated for some cheap rent uh sold
my old car to get a cheaper one but i
had a bunch of rollover costs because i
was a 21 year old that didn't know
anything about money well you're a beast
now young man by the way thank you for
your service to our country you're a
great american
oh thank you so much sir
thank you so much for the call hunter
that's awesome you hear that ken i was
21 i did some dumb stuff
you've been there i've been there yeah
but he decided at some point he said i'm
not gonna live like this anymore there's
a better way ninety thousand in the hole
and uh if i'm doing some quick math
which you know is dangerous
he's paid off about 68 70 grand worth of
debt in nine months somewhere in that
range he's a rock star while serving our
country
i'll take that wow
so much good stuff here folks keep
calling us triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number i'm
george campbell that's ken coleman this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
psalm 16 11. you make known to me the
path of life
in your presence is the fullness of joy
at your right hand are pleasures forever
colin powell once said there are no
secrets to success it is the result of
preparation hard work and learning from
failure
sad news of his passing this morning
yeah true great american hero um
pretty crazy you know it's like you you
don't hear about public figures for a
while and
i think i had forgotten or i never knew
that he was suffering from cancer and
then you hear the news today and it's
like there's a when you talk about
somebody like him you're talking about
you know i was a high schooler
um you know desert storm
and then you go through the the
different administrations the first
african-american secretary of state it's
a certainly a historical figure uh in
american history and uh
sad sad sad to see him
uh pass uh it's hard to believe yeah
yeah crazy stuff all right let's go to
the phone lines they're open right now
and we've got kyle in chicago illinois
kyle welcome to the ramsay show
thank you glad to be talking to you
gentlemen as well
so
i would like to bless my wife with a
surprise vacation all right and we have
really close friends who happen to be
our neighbors
and the husband and i talked and we
would like to send our wives together as
a surprise
the question is a moral one because
from what he's shared and from other
conversations that we've had about
finances
they're
having a hard time to put it mildly and
so
what i don't what i'm concerned about is
encouraging
a poor financial decision
in order to bless our wives together and
so what i want to do is negotiate those
boundaries without being up in their
business but also not uh
asking asking him to
put themselves in a tougher spot given
that the holidays are coming up they've
mentioned that they may even need to
purchase a vehicle here pretty soon
but there's no cash in the bank
unfortunately
for them so you are cash flowing this
vacation for your wife but you're saying
hey if she goes with her her friend
she's gonna have to put that on a credit
card and come back home with a bunch of
debt precisely that's correct
well can i ask why
this came up uh was just something that
you guys are very very close with them
and so you guys start talking about
doing this for your wives that's really
cool you guys are standing around the
trash can or something in the driveway
and then by the time you guys cook this
idea up
uh then he tells you later that their
financial uh situation is pretty bad is
that what happened
not exactly uh the my understanding of
their financial situation had been
uh somewhat progressive in nature but it
kind of became clear when
uh when he described how they would pay
for how he would pay for it right so
so why don't you just send your wife on
the thing and uh
or you're saying you wanted her to go
with this girlfriend that's the whole
point of this
uh yeah for
for for the moms to get away from the
kids our oldest son is seven and he's uh
he's one of four and they have a lot of
kids that are all little as well so they
because they're basically best friends
we thought it would be
nice for the both of them to do it
together how much more would it cost
to uh pick up her portion
uh
for both of them together it would be
three grand so right about 1500 bucks
can you do that or would that stretch
you
uh
i believe we can it would be tight we
would not need to
dip into our emergency fund it would not
compromise our savings for christmas
either it would be tight but it can be
done we could cash flow it all right
well i'm not telling you to do that i'm
just digging here because at some point
we got to be grown-ups
and you got to go ahead and if this was
your idea
hey come along come along come along and
they go okay we can do it but we'll have
to put on a card i understand how that
could feel you're going to feel the
weight it's more about how you're going
to feel
than what position they're going to be
in and i think it's a cool idea to
cashflow if you guys are that close and
you want to bless them with this gift um
that's an awesome thing but i also think
you have an honest conversation with the
buddy yeah yeah i'm not suggesting kyle
that you make your personal budget tight
to do this it's just you i was trying to
show you you got two options i think you
called us to basically say what should i
do right
yeah exactly well you either you either
bless them and you make a bit of a
sacrifice in order to bless them or you
sit down with them and go hey dude
listen i am not trying to talk you into
living the way we live happy to answer
questions about the way we live why we
do this with our money because i think
it can help you and i really would like
to help you but i don't want to cross
the boundary our friendship to you guys
matters don't want to infringe you know
because then we keep it as healthy as
possible there but hey i don't think
this is a good idea for you guys and i
kind of feel bad about it like i just
don't think this is a good idea what are
your thoughts like you gotta have a
grown-up conversation here how do you
think he would respond to that kind of
conversation
uh i think he would be kind and cordial
on the front end but i i i'm not
convinced that there's humility there to
uh
get that close in terms of uh perhaps it
being an opportunity to reconsider some
uh things
i feel like you send her on the solo
vacation and you get out of the moral
dilemma here i think so too
yeah would she not have as much fun with
that just being on her own
she might uh she she definitely needs
her alone time too that that is
definitely an option or you tweak the
vacation to be a lot you know less
expensive
and you go okay we can do a long weekend
in a nearby city and do some fun things
that's a thought too yeah see kyle
here's the deal
based on your response which by the way
if you ever decide to run for congress
that was a wonderful answer the way you
kind of you kind of moved around that
direct question
um i i
this is not your problem i understand
your heart for your neighbors and your
close friends i understand that you had
a wonderful you got a wonderful heart
it's not your problem like all of a
sudden this has turned into i want to
bless my wife because she needs some
time away to oh what do i do about my
neighbors it's not that's the wrong
question it's like what do you want to
do for your wife do that for your wife
it's not your responsibility and by the
way
if he if you were to say all the things
that you said and i loved the roundabout
you're very nice man he was like well i
don't know if he has even look he's
going to get offended
so now you're in a sich a situation
where we've talked about this idea
and
there's not much you can do about it
he's going to do what he wants to do
and uh
there's just no easy fix here man this
isn't your problem um there's got to be
some hard conversations and hard
decisions but i don't like the idea of
putting them in debt
right but i mean
you don't have a moral dilemma you've
done nothing wrong here you came up with
a nice idea to bless your wife and her
for her girlfriend
well you didn't know what their
financial situation was
so
um
i don't know well i send my wife away
that's what i would do stacy coleman
deserves a vacation yeah if mama needs
some time away i'm and i got the cash i
want to take care of mama i i'd love for
her to have a friend with her but at the
end of the day what matters most and i
love the idea of her going on the solo
vacation he goes hey well you guys did
that with cash how'd you do that oh we
had marge in the budget because we
follow this plan and maybe he sees that
and goes hey i'd like to learn a little
more and you do it on his terms and
you're not shoving the plan down his
throat and next year
they're debt-free and they go hey let's
do a vacation together
cash
that'd feel a lot better to me
yeah
and you get your buddy on the same page
all those conversations are well and
good until somebody just has a stiff
neck about it and goes well you're weird
and all that kind of stuff so now you're
going okay what do i want the
relationship to be like you know how's
this gonna mean this is something that
you just got to be a big boy and kind of
walk through this and not make your
decisions
based on
you know what they're doing and how
they're living yeah maybe not the joint
vacation idea after all no
well ken as we wrap this hour we got a
lot of questions around career and
purpose around here i want to let people
know that they can actually call into
your show every single day how do they
do that where can they find the show
844-747-2577-844-747-2577 we're live
the phone number is
from 12 to 2 eastern standard time uh
just uh steps away in studio b and you
can come watch it live you can come
watch it live we had a great crowd
watching live today it's always fun and
if you just want a bigger shovel or
you're trying to answer the question
what am i supposed to do with my life
can i make income
and an impact the answer is yes
that's what we do and that's why we do
it so we'd love to hear from you i love
it well hey two shows in a row ken
that's a win in my book it's been a
blast hosting with you i want to thank
our producer ben hill our associate
producer and phone screener kelly daniel
i want to thank you america for
listening in to some life-changing
content here on the ramsay show we'll be
back with you before you know it until
then
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously this has been the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you